[Music]
the French Revolution brought an end to
an established government it threw
France into chaos and it pushed Europe
into war but what were the events that
led to this violent transformative
upheaval hi I'm rich Burnett for
wondriam and in this episode of
perspectives three historians walk us
through the French Revolution they'll
start with its core tenants and they
move onward to its bloody conclusion
We Begin now with a look at how French
dissidents became enraged enough to
change the world
beginning in 1789 and continuing for a
full decade the French Revolution didn't
come out of nowhere
the century that preceded it brought new
ideas priorities and politicized
constituencies
the old regime had resisted these
pressures for decades
and then a financial crisis married
ineffective leadership with social
unrest and ideological challenges proved
overwhelming
Louis XVI had come to the throne in 1774
and was the last of the bourbon Dynasty
the dynasty that had ruled France since
1589.
the Bourbons enjoyed certain advantages
that their English counterparts did not
whereas the English King and Parliament
battled for Supremacy throughout the
17th century
French monarchs didn't have to contend
with an independent legislature
also France had nothing analogous to
England's Magna Carta or America's Bill
of Rights
the French King was the law
and the source of all authority
under the king three Estates comprise
the rest of society
the first estate the second estate and
the Third Estate
the clergy who were considered closest
to God below the Monarch constituted the
first estate
they numbered about 100 000 people out
of a population of 25 million
the second estate encompassed the French
nobility numbering about four hundred
thousand
the Third Estate consisted of everyone
else from peasants to Artisans and
wealthy non-noble merchants
privileged flowed down at the discretion
of those on the higher ranks but in time
a growing number of French intellectuals
found the situation irrational and
unjust
especially compared to the system of
constitutional rule arising out of
England's Glorious Revolution of 1688
and 1689.
in a period of intellectual ferment
known as the enlightenment extending
roughly from 1715 to 1789.
social critics published books and
pamphlets detailing religious
intolerance
social inequality and the arbitrary rule
of despots
Enlightenment figures such as monoskew
diedero Rousseau and Voltaire ridiculed
and derided these bedrocks of French
society
rumors songs jokes pamphlets and even
pornography with a political theme
reached a wide swath of the French
population
and normalized irreverence for
institutions formally held as sagrosanct
such commentary was risky many dissident
authors were jailed for challenging the
political and social orders
and the bonds of loyalty that tethered
the public to the old regime were
gradually whittling away
indeed the doomed Louis XVI was the
subject of revolved speculation from the
moment he ascended the throne
for most of the first decade of his
marriage to the Austrian princess Marie
Antoinette the royal couple failed to
produce an heir which was one of their
most important obligations
as years passed cartoons and illegal
pamphlets lampooned Louis as impotent
both in and out of his bedroom
his wife was cast as a Austrian
by the time the first of their four
children was born after eight years of
matrimony the heir of veneration that
seemed requisite for monarchy had
evaporated
still this wouldn't have been sufficient
on its own to spark a revolution
Revolution required a Matchstick
and that was to be the Fallout from the
American Revolution
a colonized people now proposed with the
rhetoric of Liberty and equality to
throw off monarchical Rule and introduce
a new system of government
the Americans inspired many Frenchmen at
the same time
the French involvement in the American
Revolution put an unsustainable strain
on the French economy
French assistants came on top of
Reckless spending by the king and queen
when growing numbers of subjects were
struggling to cope with the drastically
Rising prices of basic Goods including
bread
to make matters worse a rigid feudal
structure made the French clergy and
nobility tax exempt
leaving Louis with limited means to
revive his depleted Treasury
the Monarch had no choice but to appeal
to representatives of the higher orders
for help
instead of rubber stamping a new tax
system as Louis requested the king's
privileged subjects called for a meeting
of an Estates General a Country-Wide
representative body that had last met in
1614.
The Hope was that through this National
body French Elites could establish
greater Liberty and solvency while also
making inroads against the Monarch's
absolutism
brought to a heel King Louis XVI agreed
to convene the national deliberative
body
the parliament of Paris the main Law
Court decreed that the Estates General
would meet exactly as it had in 1614.
each estate would sit separately and all
votes would proceed by order
while the Third Estate would have a
voice in National Affairs the deck was
nevertheless still stacked in favor of
the elites
the first and second Estates formed a
natural Coalition a sort of voting block
or informal caucus that served as a
perennial check on the Third Estate
for the first and second Estates the
clergy and the aristocracy the smallness
of their numbers did not mean marred for
a month they refused to meet with the
Third Estate as equals consequently on
June 17th of 1789 the representatives of
the Third Estate all
578 of them declared themselves a
National Assembly of the people tasked
with creating a constitution they
invited the representatives from the
first and second Estates to join them or
not
in essence what the Reps for the Third
Estate did along with a small but
growing number of defectors from the
first and second Estates was proclaimed
that their National Assembly represented
the French Nation
ecstatic messages of support for the
self-proclaimed National Assembly poured
into Paris from all over France
of course this went over with King Louis
XVI and his people like the proverbial
barbed wire jockstrap that is it didn't
go over well at all even as the king
revoked the National Assembly and its
stinking plan to write a constitution
French soldiers most of them foreign
mercenaries began to pour into Paris
convinced that Louis and his government
were about to crush the assembly by
force the mob took to the streets and
rioting and looting broke out in Paris
the writers French Patriots if you
supported them Lawless thugs if you did
not needed weapons so on July 14 1789 a
mob attacked that symbol of Royal
Authority the Bastille Fortress which
housed a substantial Armory
a allr
friends exploded across France civil
Authority crumbled like a weak old
croissant on July 17 1789 Louis XVI
having been abandoned by the sharp end
of his monarchy meaning the Army was
forced to do the unthinkable
hat in hand he called on the assembly at
its headquarters in paris's hotel
DeVille City Hall where he endured the
ritual humiliation of putting on the
circular red white and blue cocaid or
Badge of the Revolution and bowing his
head in submission to his new Masters in
the National Assembly
on August 4th with a stroke of the pen
the National Assembly abolished the
nation's traditional system of feudalism
the National Assembly now constituted a
new center of national Authority
and on August 27th inspired by the
Americans Declaration of Independence
the National Assembly articulated its
Declaration of the rights of man and of
the citizen
it made clear that men were born and
remain free and equal in rights
in looking to establish a new
relationship between the government and
the governed National Assembly delegates
stressed that the aim of all political
associations was to preserve rights to
Liberty property security and to resist
depression
moreover sovereignty was to reside in
the nation as constituted by its
citizens
it would be difficult to overestimate
the political or intellectual
significance of this French declaration
it transformed the nation's people from
subjects
into citizens
UCLA historian Lynn hunt contends that
whatever Forum the new government might
take once the Constitution was written
the Declaration of Rights made clear
that the source of the government's
legitimacy now flowed from its guarantee
of individual rights
still
France remained a monarchy and form if
not substance
in order for the Declaration of Rights
to have the full weight of law it had to
be ratified by the king
and he hesitated
a few weeks later Parisian commoners
resolved to exert their sovereignty once
more
incensed by continuing shortages of
bread and the King's unwillingness to
endorse the August decrees some 7 000
Parisian women armed with swords muskets
broomsticks and pitchforks marched on
Versailles in October
reinforced by several thousand male
members of the self-appointed National
Guard
the women compelled Louis XVI to sign
the decrees ending feudalism and
guaranteeing rights to man and citizen
in addition the king and his family were
forced to leave the Royal residence and
relocate to paris's Tulare Palace where
it was thought the common people could
keep a better eye on them
meanwhile the National Assembly debated
key Notions about the future of France
and in September 1791 the assembly
unveiled a formal Constitution
absolute monarchy gave way to a
constitutional monarchy
the Monarch would rule in accordance
with the law and the law would be
articulated by a body to be called the
Legislative Assembly elected by the
citizens
still fundamental inequalities remained
you had to be a male property owner to
be considered an active citizen with
full political rights the rest of the
population including women servants and
the poor enjoyed certain civil rights
but could not actively participate in
the functions of government including
voting
the situation rankled many
especially a growing group of radical
working-class men and women known as the
sunkulats literally those without
breaches since they were long pants
rather than the breeches and Silk
Stockings of the will to do
Louis XVI added to their distrust in
June 1791.
with Emma Gray Aristocrats organizing
counter-revolutionary forces on France's
borders
the king and his family tried to join
them
he never made it out of the country
recognized in a small town close to the
Border he was stripped of a disguise
he'd adopted and returned to Paris in
disgrace
soon
the radicalization of the masses was
also pushed Along by Foreign Wars
expecting an attack from the monarchies
of Austria and Prussia which were
determined to Halt the revolution
France launched a preemptive strike in
April 1792 in a bid for
self-preservation
radical political figures and writers
inflamed the situation
journalists like Jean-Paul Mara warned
the public that the government of France
plotted against the well-being of the
people
morat argued that the revolution's
enemies preached peace confidence and
respect for the laws in order to prevent
the explosion of the people's Justified
anger
morale's predicted explosion came during
the dog days of summer
news of strategic losses fueled
anxieties about a foreign Invasion and
the fall of Paris itself
The Rage of sankulatz who engaged in a
daily struggle against inflation and
food shortages and suspected their King
and his Austrian wife of treachery
erupted on August 10 1792.
militant sankulats stormed the tularies
palace on August 10 1792.
Royal and swiss guards opened fire to
Stave off the rebels
but this made the sankulat still more
determined
the Royal Guards were overwhelmed and
slaughtered
the monarchy was overthrown
the Legislative Assembly tried to tone
down the violence
but inflammatory figures such as Murat
and the lawyer turned member of the
legislative assembly Maximilian world's
Pierre denounced the calls for com as
counter-revolutionary
tension that prevailed in Paris that
summer led the new government to arrest
thousands of aristocrats former Royal
officials and members of the clergy
whom its sense could be party to account
a revolution
as rumors swirled about imprisoned
royalists and Aristocrats conspiring
with invading foreign armies angry mobs
stormed Parisian prisons and murdered
some 1 200 prisoners
Aristocrats clergy and common criminals
in Cold Blood
in what became known as the September
massacres
radical organizers and members of an
outspoken political Club known as the
Jacobins who included maraud Robespierre
and Georges dantong
defended the violence
Moross said that if a mistaken Humanity
cripples the arms of Revolution and
holds back its blows
it will cost the lives of millions of
our brothers
the discredited legislative assembly now
gave way to a new more democratic body
called the National Convention
and with the monarchy overthrown
the National Convention declared France
a republic
within it the radical Jacobin contingent
drove the next phase of the revolution
calling for patriotism sacrifice and
decisive action
led by Robespierre and dantong they
believed that the French Republic was
the Vanguard of a crusade for Universal
Liberty
the question of what to do with Louis
XVI became one of the most divisive
issues the newly established National
Convention faced
one faction the gerund East
spouse moderation they wanted to put the
issue to a people's referendum
but the Jacobins insisted on the king's
execution
the most Ardent and public proponent of
the king's execution was Robespierre his
fiery passionate rhetoric convinced a
slight majority of the National
Convention to support his efforts
in Robespierre's words
the king needed to die so that the Petri
should be able to live
momentum turned in the Jacobins favor
after a box of treacherous
correspondence between the king and
foreign courts was discovered in
November 1792.
the revolution now took a turn from
which there was no return
and so citizen cape
formally Louis XVI was guillotined in
January 1793.
this brought several other European
States including Britain Spain and
Holland into a state of war against
France to stem the Revolutionary tide
the National Convention formed a
Committee of Public Safety to deal with
the existential threat from abroad and
at home
it would function as a special Tribunal
to punish Traders conspirators and
agitators
riots rocked Paris in the spring and
summer of 1793. as many as 80 000 people
stormed the new National legislative
body in June
three in 1794 France endured a period
sometimes called the reign of terror
newly empowered rulers sought to find
and punish anyone who had allegedly
supported the old regime
newly formed committees and tribunals
considered charges against those who
were branded as enemies of the new state
there was a sense in France that
everything had been reset
the new revolutionary calendar restarted
from year one it renamed the months of
the year according to the seasons using
in their stead French words for a Mist
Frost snow rain wind flowers and harvest
for example what was formerly known as
mid-july to mid-august was called
Thermador meaning Heat
August into September was renamed
fruchtador for fruit
new festivals were put in place in order
to de-christianize the country as the
Catholic Church too was viewed as
tyrannical
if the system was not atheist
in the place of the Catholic God the New
Order declared a cult of the Supreme
Being it declared nature as the priest
the universe as the temple and virtue
happiness Universal Brotherhood and pure
heartedness as its highest values anyone
found to be outside of virtue might be
at risk for execution by guillotine
meanwhile to deal with their foreign
enemies the convention instituted a
general draft of unmarried childless men
between the ages of 18 and 25
bringing more than 700 000 men into the
French military
they marched into battle with the
defiant Hymn of the newly composed la
marseillaise
the French national anthem running
through their heads
The Anthem vowed to defend the
Fatherland in the name of Liberty
in the winter of 1793 and 1794 the
French did suppress significant domestic
rebellions while pushing back the
austrians and containing the British
some of Robespierre's colleagues argued
that with the military situation
improving the terror should abate
foremost among them was Georges Danton
perhaps the only other member of the
Committee of Public Safety with as much
political clout as Robespierre
but Robespierre refused to tolerate any
hint of dissent
in early April 1794 the downtown east
including Georges Danton went to the
guillotine
and in June 1794 the law of 22 prairiel
was passed denying accused persons of
access to Illegal defense
in addition
the law stipulated that there could be
only two legitimate sentences for the
accused acquittal
or death
as a result the number of those
Guillotines soared encompassing some
1285 individuals in Paris over the next
seven weeks alone
the use of the guillotine became almost
commonplace during the terror in the end
at least 17 000 people were tried and
executed not everyone got a trial
whether fair or not
it's estimated that as many as 40 000
people were put to death
One Source concludes that only 15
percent of that number were clergy and
nobility
the rest were from the bourgeoisie the
petite bourgeoisie the laborers and The
Peasants the classes that had initially
banded together to seek political and
social change
after the French achieved a decisive
Victory against the austrians that same
month ending a threat of invasion many
people expected an end to Terror
justified by the emergency of War
but that was not to be
instead Weeks Later
Robespierre denounced denounced an
unnamed group of Traders whom he accused
of plotting a conspiracy
this was too much for members of the
convention
many of Robespierre's former colleagues
and followers having seen so many
Frenchmen lose their heads to the
guillotine now turned against him before
he could turn on them
on July 27 1794 a battle broke out
between robespierce supporters and
National Guard troops leaving
Robespierre with a self-inflicted
gunshot wound
but the anti-robosphere forces prevailed
Robespierre was arrested and executed
and that proved to be a turning point in
the revolution
it empowered a movement known as the
thermadorian reaction which divested the
Committee of Public Safety of power and
reauthorized the National Convention
over the next few years radicalism was
expunged and violence was brought under
control
the French Revolution with its Universal
pledges of Liberty equality and
fraternity
transformed the modern era
but it came at quite the cost
years later the Soviet revolutionary
poet Vladimir makovsky observed that
revolutions forcefully hurl their
participants
and a revolutions bystanders into the
great unknown
so perhaps we shouldn't be surprised
when revolutions grow violent and
infused with Terror
maybe we should be surprised when they
don't
thanks for watching if you'd like to
learn more about the topics in this
episode the full list of series that
these clips came from is in the
description below you can watch them all
now on wandria